this is grand master daniel neridinski
we are watching magnus carlsen taking on
fabiano caruana the 2010 fiji world
blitz championship in a pretty tame
opening magnus carlson playing 1d4 and
caruana responding with a slav as he
takes on c4 this is a main line of the
slav defense and generally white plays
the move e2 e3 here and wins back the
pawn on c4 and that is exactly what is
happening as caruana develops his knight
to d7 the black dark square bishop it
generally heads to b4 in these positions
that is a square that was weakened by
white's move a2 a4 and white plays a4 to
prevent black's b-pawn from shifting up
to b5 this is still theory but magnus
making a rare move as far as i know as
he moves his pawn from a4 to a5 a very
ambitious sideline trying to grab as
much space as possible on the queen side
and he follows it up by occupying the
square that was cleared up by the pawn
queen d1 to a4 a very unconventional way
of playing but caruana he responds very
quickly and i like the way he responds
as he moves his queen from d8 to e7
stabilizing the bishop on b4 and both
sides castle and kingside
and this looks like it's going to be a
long
brutal positional struggle as both sides
have castled to the same side and magnus
moving his bishop away from c4 to e2
that is a very typical magnus move kind
of a mysterious bishop move and why is
he vacating the c4 square i think he was
trying to defend against the prospect of
fabby pushing the b-pawn up to b5 that
would have led to a fork on the queen
and the bishop magnus kind of
unpassanted there but he faced the
prospect of losing his light squad
bishop and that is one of white's most
important pieces in this complex middle
game how is fabby going to improve his
position well there's the answer as he
moves his knight from f6 to e4 an
ambitious move in his own right offering
a trade of knights but controlling key
central squares with his minor pieces
and now he is threatening to take
carlson's knight on c3 twice and win a
pawn so my guess is that magnus has to
respond to that threat he's gonna have
to do something about his c3 knight and
he does something indeed and what he
does he moves his queen back to b3
and then he made that move with
authority as he defends the knight on c3
and continues to keep the pressure alive
on fabby's dark square bishop and the
battle is revolving around who can
control key central squares and will
carlson be able to repel fabby's queen
side pressure will he be able to
ultimately get rid of that dark square
bishop which is pestering magnus on
before and there's the answer is fabi
gets rid of that bishop himself there
was something he didn't like about the
pressure the queen was exerting on the
bishop and that is why fabi put his rook
on b8 he did that in order to defend the
b7 pawn and make the bishop retreat
possible in a trade now on e4 as fabi
maintains his big time advantage and
carlson drops his other knight back to
d2 still playing pretty quietly still
aiming for the long-term positional game
here as he chases the bishop out of the
center and fabi can put it back to g6 he
can also put it on d5 but if he does
that then he runs the risk of the bishop
getting trapped if magnus pushes his e
pawn up to e4 but yep
caruana going bishop back to g6 and that
was the idea of magnus's last move as
the knight is maneuvered from f3 to c4
putting pressure on the other bishop and
now magnus could try bishop d2 in order
to try to snuggle that bishop up to b4
and skewer fabi's queen and rook and
that is exactly what he does that is a
threat which must be addressed bobby can
move the rook from f8 he can also move
his queen but the big threat is carlson
jumping up to b4 and rook fda is indeed
on the board carlson could still put his
bishop on b4 that looks like a very nice
square for his dark square bishop and i
like the way that carlson is handling
the middle game he's developed something
of an initiative as he forces fabi's
queen out into the open and the queen
lands on g5 x-raying the pawn on g2 so
carlson he cannot fall asleep on the
prospect of certain kingside threats
that can eventually appear if phabby
moves more of his pieces toward the king
side and carlson taking a long thing
here as he's as he looks for ways to
continue improving his position he can
bring the rook on a one into the game he
decides instead to put the bishop on a
better square bishop e2 to f3 that was
also preventing
fabi's own bishop from jumping back into
e4 and threatening checkmate on g2 a
good prophylactic move and there's also
the prospect of the a5 pawn pushing up
to a6 and weakening the c6 pawn because
fabi that c6 pawn is defended by the b7
pawn so fabi faces the prospect of queen
side pressure pressure in the center i
think black is slightly worse here and
caruana has to play very very carefully
in the next couple of moves magnus has
always been a legend in these types of
quiet maneuvering games and he's proving
that yet again it's fabinho taking a
long thing here trying to figure out a
way to keep his position stable he's got
many options here he can play the move
a6 himself and he does just that
immobilizing carlson's pawn on a5 but
the drawback of that move is that a hole
has been created on b6 and that is a
later outpost for white's knight at the
moment that square is safely defended
right now by fabi's bishop as the knight
drops into f6 and maybe fabi is flirting
with the idea of some pressure on
carlson's king maybe a bishop e4 move
could come but carlson exploiting the
drawback of fabi's last move as he
maneuvers his bishop into c5 and now the
huge threat is bishop c5 to a7 chasing
the rook out of b8 and if the rook is
chased out of b8 then fabi's gonna lose
his b7 pawn and the b7 pawn anchors the
entire queen side so this is a threat
which must be addressed but fabi is
dropping now to below a minute on the
clock as he looks at both sides intently
you can see the concentration as he
tries to find a way to keep his position
from falling apart bishop a7 is a
massive threat but fabi finds a nice
tactical solution rook to d7 creating a
potential x-ray the queen cannot take on
b7 because of the prospect of bishop h2
check so
carlson stops on a dime and he puts his
bishop not on a7 but on b6 that is the
hole that was created by fabby pushing
his pawn to a6 and he takes with the
queen a little bit of hesitation there
carlson wants to keep his knight in the
center maybe he wants to jump into e5
and fabby tries to smoke that queen out
of b6 and smoke it out he does but the
queen moves to an even better square
moves to c5 and x-rays the knight on d5
and now the big threat is e3 e4 winning
the knight on d5 there is a pin against
black's queen on g5 and that is why fabi
plays h6 he does that to defend the
queen to take the sting out of the move
e4 now carlson could play it anyway but
instead he plays b4 he continues
expanding on the queen side but fabi he
has a very solid position nonetheless
those pawns on a6 and c6 are preventing
the further progress of carlson's b-pawn
and carlson has to keep his foot on the
gas pedal because fabio will continue
making improving moves and he is 30
seconds up on the clock maybe a little
bit of frustration there as fabby drops
his bishop back to h7 a kind of cat and
mouse game both sides making small
improving moves but fabi he continues to
his clock continues to fade and
continues to dwindle he just moved his
bishop from h7 to g6 a clear sign that
fabi does not know what to do he is out
of improving moves but he is more than
fine to sit if carlson does the same but
carlson continues to wind his tentacles
around black's position bit by bit he's
improved his knight now he plays g3 to
tuck his light squared bishop on g2 out
of the grasp of black screen and fabby
maneuvers his knight to b5 what a tense
position but carlson seems to be making
a lot more progress
fabby going back and forth with his
knight he moves to d6 carlson blocks the
square with e4 and fabby jumps back to
b5 but now he's putting pressure on
carlson's center that d4 pawn is under a
lot of fire and the knight drops back to
g4 now fabby's queen is on an incredibly
awkward square it's on g6 it's blocking
the bishop on h7 the clock is down to
15. fabby with a little bit of panic
there as he plays the move f6 out of
necessity that is a very weakening move
and bang goes the dynamite d5 by carlson
blasting through in the center and the
pressure has gotten critical as he
doubles his rooks in the devil and if
the defile opens is fabby's pieces are
they going to be well enough equipped to
handle the opening of the position i
don't think so rook takes d5 by carlos
and the pressure continues to grow rook
dc8 fabio refuses the rook trade he
keeps both of his rooks to defend the
eighth rank queen b6 by carlson he
threatens now to infiltrate with the
move rook to d8 and where is he going to
go with his rook he can also put it on
d7 there was something there that was
frustrating him as fabio finally finds a
way to move his bishop into the game as
he moves into g8 and now carlson's clock
is dwindling and it's down to 20 seconds
a lot of hesitation there from carlson
and he moved his rook back to d2 there
was something he didn't like about rook
d7 and now he improves his knight and
moves it to e3 carlson
trying to continue pressuring 93 to d5
and fabi offered a queen trade and the
queen's in a standoff and carlson
finally accepts it and finally after
about 30 moves it's the knight that
moves into b6 something we would we
thought would happen a lot earlier
bishop db3 is both sides an acute time
pressure 20 seconds on the clock for
both of them but what worries me about
black's position here is that pawn on b7
that's a huge weakness and after knight
takes d7 the knight jumps back to c5 and
caruana he's going to lose the pawn on
b7 he's going to lose the pawn on b7
it's attacked by two different pieces
and with that pawn on b7 goes into goes
his entire queen side he's also going to
lose a6 last ditch attempt by caruana to
create counter play carlson could not
have taken a6 there because of the fork
on e2 or a check on f3 rookie one is an
amazing move in time pressure and the
king moves up to f2 and caruana cannot
take on f4 because of king e3 forking
the rook in the night
what exquisite technique from carlson as
the king moves out of danger and now
it's on f3 and now i think he can safely
take the pawn on a6 but a little bit of
hesitation from carlson and take it he
does he takes it with the knight caruana
still trying to get active with his
pieces to create threads bishop to c4
how is carlson going to manage this
final spur of activity he goes rook to
c1 skewering black's pieces carolina
plays rook b3 knight to c5 king to f2
moving out of the discovery and carlson
has managed to keep both of his extra
pawns intact he's completely winning as
he pushes up to asics and carolina
continues to try rick knight a2 and
knight c3 and now carlson plays rook b3
and a rook trade is deadly for black
and now black's pieces are getting
pushed around where is carlson's king
going to go it shifts away to f3 another
check on e2 and the king moves up to e4
this is absolutely amazing technique by
carlson he is not giving fabi a single
chance but fabi continues to harass him
bishop e2 to c4 there is a nasty check
on e2 which he might deliver and he goes
g6 he's trying to set up a mating net
rookie to check is incredibly unpleasant
and carlson's pawns for the time being
are somehow immobilized by black's
pieces as he moves his rook back from g3
to g1 attacking the knight knight f2
check king e3 and the knight takes the
pawn on h3 and
caruana has almost re-established
material equality but now his knight is
completely out of the game and rook a3
check and carlson continues to get
annoyed bishop b3 bishop takes a6 he's
won another pawn but rook h1 traps the
knight and he takes the knight and
caruana takes the bishop but king t4
wins the bishop on b3 the bishop cannot
move because the rook is going to be
lost and shake of hands from caruana
what a game by carlson and if you
enjoyed this video make sure to click
the link in the playlist for more of
these videos thank you so much for
watching
[Music]